pour le moment il est 22h30 et je vous
avais promis quelque chose
d'exceptionnel selon lui il est bien une
zone jaune en plus je n'en peux plus me
connaissent je défends mais c'est avec
les deux ans on sait pas comment s'en
débarrasser mais en deux minutes il nous
a débarrassé de mathieu qui va revenir
dans un instant pour le moment les
chéris va se passer un truc fou je vous
le dis je suis très très fier de cette
émission de l'avoir fait avec vous parce
que vous avez été formidables
j'espère que vous passez un bon moment
avec nous ce soir nous sommes bien sûr
en direct et yaitanes c'est un jeune
garçon qui nous envoyait une vidéo
il voulait offrir quelque chose à sa
mère céline regarder ben je mentais
l'état gino van geyte de petit frère
enzo et nomade
je voudrais offrir plein de choses à ma
maman pas parce que je travaille
beaucoup pour nous trois ici il te reste
un peu d'argent
je voudrais une chance magnifique traire
que pour mon papa je t'aime elle mois
offrait un gros cadeau pour ma maman
je crois que céline est là avec ses
trois enfants ce soir est ce que céline
peut venir nous rejoint elle pleure des
céline bien devoir bien voir c'est bien
là céline applaudissements pour ces
lignes quelques avec bonsoir ces lignes
plein vous êtes magnifique alors
vraiment vous êtes vraiment magnifique
vous avez trois enfants qui sont nos
publics enzo et anne et nolan
oui ils sont là et ici on ils sont avec
les agressions avec eux c'est leur
service et leur mamie qu'on embrasse
moche on m'a dit bonjour mamie elle est
l ampleur des chômage
vous vous êtes cela avec vos enfants
vous avez 34 ans oui c'est ça je le
donne là je pense que vous êtes jeune
donc on a le droit d'accord après nom
donne plus ici autour de la table on
donne tout céline c'est vrai que c'est
pas c'est pas facile tous les jours je
crois savoir
et comme on l'a vu et anne il aimerait
avoir une nouvelle chambre parce qu'ils
sont les trois enfants sont dans la même
sûrement fait c'est un oui bon c'est
vous gagnez 680 euros par mois ça fait
quoi comme travail
je suis travail dans les écoles je suis
enfin l'assistance de visites scolaires
vous êtes assistants de vie scolaire
j'aimerais que les enfants viennent de
rejoindre parce que j'ai une petite
surprise pour eux
dans la motion j'adore et très polis
bonjour bonjour comment ça va mon chéri
bien ça va tu travaillé à l'école
oui moyens mais non bien comment ça va
bien ça va et comment tu t'appelles
eh bien je sais ça va tu es contente est
devenu avec maman ici
oui c'est comment je m'appelle oui
comment un maire c'est magnifique ça va
peut-être tu nous regardes les mamans
les gentils c'est un amour s'occupe bien
de vous oui et mamie elle est gentille
aussi oui un ami ça va mal mais ça me va
bien
bon mes chéris vous êtes l'étroit dans
une même chambre
donc on a voulu vous faire un petit
cadeau ce soir je vous le dis on a voulu
vous offrir trois magnifiques chambres
pour vos enfants une chambre pour chacun
voilà donc on va refaire les trois
chambres donc vous auriez cette chambre
là cette chambre la tronche et cette
chambre là vous allez avoir chacun vos
chambres les enfants donc ma chérie ça y
est il ya plus de problème et anne va
être content céline c'est bon alors
arrêtez pleurer sinon tout le monde va
pleurer non mais c'est vrai mais bon le
problème qu'il ya c'est que est-ce que
vous avez la place de mettre les trois
chambres dans la maison venait d'ouvrir
par l'abonné par la scène est-ce que
vous avez la place de mettre les trois
chambres dans la maison c'est son
problème
c'est ça le problème c'est vrai que
parce que je me dis si on met les trois
chambres
vous vivez dans un coma de carrie 68
mètres car il en faudrait qu'on fasse
des ça va être fou de québécois à être
compliqué ce soir c'est noël et ce soir
j'ai envie de vous offrir un peu plus
que les trois chambres
regardez dans l'écran céline
ce soir est ce qu'on peut faire tomber
la bâche s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ya longtemps
[Applaudissements]
les chéris ce soir on vous offre une
maison alors on va visiter la maison
ensemble
regardez la maison c'est magnifique a
vraiment c'est à vous céline incroyable
[Applaudissements]
cette maison
c'est pour vous et vos enfants mais
chérie ça va mon chéri d'amour
[Applaudissements]
vous vivez
bonjour
[Applaudissements]
béchir y voilà la clé rivalland est-ce
que voilà c'est la clé de la maison
merci à l'éléction à l'oreille je
t'offre la clé c'est la clé de la maison
tu repars avec mon chéri c'est ta maison
alors je voudrais dire c'est des maisons
voilà je voulais remercier notre
partenaire ces maisons et c'est de là
pierre donc voilà je voulais vous dire
merci à eux parce que cette maison les
tabous et les magnifiques
vraiment c'est votre maison
je suis ravi
céline nous appeler c'est la maman de
céline quel est votre prénom
maria maria merci de ta joie
je vous remercie à tous toute l'équipe
vous avez été faisable
vous êtes un monsieur vous avez ma
virginie de vente où ils avaient mis mes
petits enfants dans le bonheur ce qui
ramène quand même et moi jamais avec
parce que ça me faisait mal au coeur
merci en tout cas mr mercier
la femme dit oui
bon marché j'ai juste un petit truc à
vous demander maintenant est ce que vous
allez ma [ __ ] et ateliers dans la maison
s'il avait bien servi avec les enfants
tu vas mavita tikva m'invite à dîner ou
pas la maison oui tu vas prépare à
manger réussit pas eh toi que tu va
préparer les meilleurs groupes est ma
vie la porte en section avec vous mais
je viendrai j'ai juré vouloir vraiment
dans la maison je dois vraiment
remercier encore notre partenaire
vraiment jolie ces maisons avec un
prénom plus loin et aux éléphants
abakar ya des représentants
merci merci c'est redal représentant
voilà célèbre également la maison avec
nous donc voila merci des rebelles et
vous pouvez les remercier mr jours toute
[Applaudissements]
l'année cela fait combien de mètres
carrés la maison ça veut plus un but 100
mètres carrés et à l'équipe de maisons
pierre est très très très dire le nom
mais c'est pas maison rédaction plus
loin pierre maison préparé par bercy est
très heureuse de vous offrir ce
magnifique cadeau c'est vrai que c'est
pas évident de l'arrivée à ce moment
autant d avec autant d'émotion on est
vraiment vraiment fier je suis hyper
content oui je voudrais dire merci aux
équipes d'âge le zoo
[Applaudissements]
et reda est-ce qu'un amour mais bon mais
sont vraiment son magnifique jour si
vous avez la maison comme elle est belle
jean-luc je crois que pour moi c'est un
des plus beaux moments de tennis
première je vois là je me les
raccompagner à sa mère si elle a été par
contre bien sûr et je viens vraiment à
la maison
d'accord vous êtes des arbres et je vous
souhaite beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de bonheur merci merci monsieur
merci à tous a encore dit
[Applaudissements]
je pense qu'avec mes enfants ont pas
c'est vrai un jour et je te fais un gros
bisou merci merci merci je te fais un
gros bisou d'amour
l'effort
[Applaudissements]